[Music]
Chris good to see my friend Gabe good
see to welcome to the studio thank you
very much for having me
I brought you something special you were
12 indeed so talk to me a bit about this
bag you made for us well I tell you when
doers came to us the idea was to create
a special bag for the intrepid traveler
someone that is always on the move
who needs to sort of put their life in
here and travel we knew doers as
obviously handcrafted so we needed to
create a bag that had a lot of
handcrafted details and so all over this
bag you're touched by hand down to every
little tubular rivet on these parts are
set by hand this is all hand stitched
even this tip is set with literally this
hammer on this steel block and then of
course you come down to the leather as
Dewar's is so complex and has all these
different notes who wanted to come up
with a leather that wasn't flat Brown
one of the complex leather that changes
over time like a barrel scotch whiskey
does and so literally that's why we came
up with this type of leather that's is
very reminiscent of sort of like a war
or two bomber jacket and really the
piece de resistance flap opens out comes
the Dewar's 12 Chris for me during
gifting season there's no better gift
than a bottle of Dewar's well now you
have the perfect bag to give one in
there's great stories to tell over
whiskey and that was great stories to
tell over whiskey and a perfect whiskey
bag cheers Chris cheers to you Gabe
[Music]